thank you guys so much for having me
here this afternoon I once it's honored
but I think the right way of phrasing is
humbled very humbled to be here I was in
your chairs well your proverbial chairs
I did not have nearly as nice of
buildings when I came here 20 years ago
and I was trying to think when I was
asked to do this speech I got the email
and my first thought was that sounds
like a lot of work I'm really busy this
fall how do I get out of it stress I
don't really have anything that relevant
or interesting to say and as soon as I
started to think about how I could make
up an excuse my computer ding then there
was a note from Heidi Roizen who's here
supporting me in the audience which
literally said you must do this and so I
realized there was no way I was getting
out of it so I had to be here today and
do this presentation and then I started
the daunting task of thinking what do I
want to say what would I have wanted to
hear when I was sitting in your seats
two decades ago what would have been
useful and um at this time I was
actually on a vacation and this is a
picture of where I was I was in Wyoming
it's one of my favorite places in the
world I go there every single summer and
I got a text from my brother said quote
kick-ass hype you game I was in a mood
of saying yes so I said sure I'm gonna
give this speech and I'll go on this
hike and as I started on this hike in
this journey and I was thought this
would be a good day to prepare for the
fall and honestly think about what I was
going to talk about I started to really
see this as a metaphor for my own
experiences over the past two decades
but also just a lot of people that I've
known a lot of the successful people a
lot of the entrepreneurs a lot of the
challenges that they face so basically
I'm going to take you through this hike
it's a behind the scenes reality of what
that experience was and kind of layering
how that's relevant for me if I have any
hope for today it's that there's
something in this presentation some
nugget of advice that is either
aspirational or comforting for you over
the next two decades of your life so Who
am I that the the intros always sound
great
Emily Melton I'm 42 years old I was the
oldest of six kids I grew up in Utah one
of my mom my mother grew up on a mink
ranch and my dad grew up on a chicken
farm and
they moved to Salt Lake to get out of
their farming community
my mom did go to college but she was
told by her college counselor that the
only school that was really relevant for
her was beauty school and so both of my
parents had a very very strong belief in
education and a very very strong belief
that I needed to leave Utah and that was
the one thing they didn't care where I
went to school like kind of cared but
they really need it had to be outside of
Utah and when I started to show some
academic progress or promise my dad
bought me a Harvard sweatshirt and I
spent the next couple of years trying to
convince him that Stanford was the
Harvard of the West now for you guys I
think we all know that Harvard is the
Stanford of the of the East so the much
easier pitch but I was grateful enough
to get to come here undergrad mm and the
GSB in 2005 I'm now one of five general
partners at D F J which is a 35 year old
venture capital firm and as was
mentioned earlier I spend a lot of my
time investing in consumer marketplaces
I was a early boarding member an
investor in red fin an online real
estate transaction platform I'm on the
board of a company called shift which is
a used car marketplace and asked to
spend a lot of time in healthcare and
pretty broadly healthcare IT services
mobile technologies and more recently
looking at AI and ml and how those can
transform diagnostics and drug discovery
so the simplicity or the simple way of
saying it I like big hairy problems that
are complex and I really love really
passionate people that are working to
solve those problems so we're going to
talk about a hike and this is where you
get the the person comes up here the
proverbial successful person and tells
you're gonna go and hike and this is
what you want to vision right you think
it's going to be someone who's really
successful this woman looks like someone
who can scale a really big you know a
big mountain and do it without breaking
sweat simply the reality is is this is
the person who hiked up the hill and we
don't have to say exactly how many
pounds over that you know previous
pitcher but many and many pounds over
from when I sat in those chairs I was
not the kind of person who was in really
good physical shape to go on the kind of
hike I wasn't necessarily thinking that
this was going to be something that I
was capable of doing
and I think that's really important when
I think about a venture capitalist when
I started I said I was political science
and philosophy undergrad here I thought
it was gonna go to law school because I
thought you know if you're successful
you get into a good college you're
either a lawyer and the doctor didn't
really like blood so I'll go be a lawyer
I applied had some success getting into
to law schools but needed to make some
money or wanted to make some money
before taking on more debt started
working in a law practice and hated it
it was 99 mm and I started getting all
these job offers because it was crazy
and they were just literally trying to
hire everybody and I remember both being
humbled by the job offers and very
confused on how these companies could
pay me so much money and why they wanted
me and I remember I sat down with one of
the CEOs who had offered me to join his
company incorp dev and I thought I'm
gonna be I'm not a business person but
I'm gonna ask the business questions
right let's spend time on the business
what are your profits well we don't have
profits what are your revenues we don't
have revenues I was like how do you have
money to pay me like how I wonder is are
you running this he said well we get
money from venture capitalists so I
thought well that makes a lot of sense I
wasn't hadn't spend time in a lot of
these rooms I didn't really fully
understand the VC industry but I
realized for me to make a good decision
on the kinds of company I wanted to go
work it I should understand the flow of
money and so through my network I sent
notes to all the VCS at all of the
companies that I was interviewing in and
one of them was Tim Draper
he offered to meet with me mostly i
sweet-talked his assistant who then made
him spend 20 minutes with me and i came
in with a list of questions about the
company and I started with the question
and he was like that's a pretty good
question there's like what you've got
there I was like it's a list of
questions like why don't you just go
through the whole list so I went through
my list of questions and at the end of
it he said those are really good
questions why don't you just come do
that for me do what it was like ask
companies that come in those questions
that's what we do we we ask them
questions and we decide whether or not
we're gonna invest so I remember I left
and I was sitting in the car in the
parking lot I called my boyfriend now my
husband is that I think I've just got a
job in venture capital so no one gets a
job in venture capital but sure enough I
got to come back in meet with more other
partners and a couple weeks later I was
first analyst that they had ever hired
so what's the minute the story this is a
woman who shouldn't be hiking up the
side of a mountain because she really
needs to hit the gym more frequently
this also is not someone who looks like
a venture capitalist I do not look like
a venture capitalist at the time I
didn't have the background and have the
experience don't let anyone else tell
you what you're capable of
don't let anyone's others views of what
you think a person should be in order to
be that successful it's an unnecessary
barrier we all talk about unconscious
bias and how that hurts others and it's
absolutely true but what's also really
important for you to all realize is
those biases those images in your head
can hurt yourself so this is the hike as
I mentioned earlier Jackson Hole Wyoming
and the Tetons in particular my happy
place it's where I find peace and I
always I am happiest when I'm in the
western mountains and I wanted to read
you the the description of the hike I
was asking my brothers we went in you
know how I knew basically it was about
15 mile hike he said it would take about
a day and as I'm driving in this is
actually on the other side so Wyoming is
on the other side of the Teton so this
is on the Idaho side this was the
description in the trail book that he
handed me as we started you know driving
into the park it's long and it's
strenuous but if you're in the physical
condition and you have the persistence
it takes you will remember for the rest
of your life it's a hike for which you
must work for it and work for your
reward but there will not be a
disappointment at the end so this is our
driving in the hike starts kind of at
that tree line and as I pull in that
little where the arrow is pointing that
kind of flat area as you look beyond and
then you see the Tetons that's where I'm
hiking up to so what's the point of this
this is kind of like the future right I
didn't know what I was getting up into I
didn't really understand what this was
actually gonna mean or what it was gonna
look like when I went up there but I had
the aspiration to figure out a way to
make my myself somehow home I bought up
to that place goals are really important
aspirations are really really important
but you don't know exactly what it's
going to be and so you have to also be
very comfortable with
certainty it's not going to ever follow
the exact path and when you look for it
in the same way that's kind of fuzzy and
it's really challenging on us exactly
what that looks like you're gonna have
the same problems you want to set a big
hairy ambitious goals but you have to
recognize that it's not gonna go exactly
as planned I have the privilege of my
job to get to meet with some of the best
entrepreneurs and some of the iconic
entrepreneurs over the last two decades
and the things that they all have in
common is he or she comes in with an
ambitious and bold goal they have a
vision of the future and almost in every
single one of those instances it never
works out exactly as they planned that
slide deck has not followed those
financial projections are completely off
but it's that ambition that pushes them
forward that gets them out that gets
them to experience their own sick levels
of success this is the the kind of thing
that struck me multiple times throughout
the hike was how the experience kept
changing as I was always going up and
like that saying the future you don't
know exactly where you're going you know
a mile in the hike was very different
than it did five miles in than it did on
the way down and I kept thinking about
the word perspective and perspective is
really relevant in two ways one it's how
you you know what you see is gonna
change based off of where you are right
as you move forward as you like this
looks different if I'm heading this way
and in this part of the room it looks
different if I'm in the back of the room
where you physically are changes how you
see the world and that's one concept and
that was absolutely true of how I
experienced this hike but the other
thing is is how you see the world
changes and what do I mean by that
because you change I am a different
person that I was when I was sitting in
the proverbial chairs two decades ago
and you were all gonna change multiple
times I continued to change the way that
I see the world today is very different
than even how I saw it just a year ago
and so that's that level of perspective
and that the contact again that comfort
with uncertainty that where you go and
as you move along the journey your
visual field there's going to change
your field of opportunity is going to
change but I'll say you're gonna change
you're going to become different and
that's okay too
so it's
as we get in on the hike we've tweet
it's actually took us some time to find
this because it wasn't particularly well
marked this is the only the only sign on
the entire trail so we saw so for those
that are on the podcast it basically
says trail not maintained very steep not
recommended what a great start right so
this is kind of you know this one of the
things is you have to be comfortable and
I commit and digging in the other thing
is is these signs are gonna appear
multiple times in your life becoming an
entrepreneur is never a rational choice
there's always an easier way to make
money or an easier way to find some
level of immediate success anything
worth doing is going to be hard anything
that gets you to those next levels and
gets you to where you want ultimate be
is going to be challenging and so
whether it's actually a physical sign
like this or someone who explicitly
tells you you can't be a VC Emily you
take political science a philosophy who
the hell do you think you are who's
gonna want your advice or it's someone
implicitly who just walks out of the
room and says there's nothing really
useful for you here don't let any of
these signs ever stop you it's not to
say that you're gonna be successful it's
not to say that it's a guarantee that
you will make it to the end but how the
hell are you gonna know if you don't
even try the trail was not maintained
and there were multiple times where we
were wandering around and one of the
things that you know you recognize
there's no journey is the same for every
person so as I'm trying to give you
advice this isn't the checklist of
here's how to get to be a successful VC
or here's how to build a successful
company or here's how to do I hate those
you know they everybody wakes up at 5:00
a.m. everyone somehow works outs
meditates eat well has great kids and
you read it you're like this is
impossible and the reality is that is
always impossible there's no checklist
there's no template for success in the
same way there's no clear trail that's
gonna tell you how to get up this hill
every single one of you is gonna have
multiple kind of challenges in your own
right every single one of you is journey
it's gonna be different but that doesn't
mean that you should go in without
action
understanding what's happened in the
past or who came before you whenever I
have an entrepreneur come and pitch me
and I they always come in really passion
I'm gonna disrupt this industry well
that's great
why hasn't happened in the past who's
tried and failed what did you learn from
those lessons that's not to say that
that because it has failed in the past
it's going to fail in the future but not
actually taking the time to understand
what is in the how it happened in the
past is putting you at risk for the
future
so as we're hiking up this trail I don't
know if you guys see the stack of rocks
and you guys know what those are called
Carens so Karan's are where you put a
stack of rock as you're walking up the
hill and if the trail is not well marked
people put karent's so the people who
come before you put those as markers so
when you don't know where to go you can
kind of look out and follow some kind of
a path this to me is like the Mentors
people in your life who've been there
before the trail is gonna be different
conditions have changed snow wind rain
to knock these things over or it doesn't
they're gonna have a day they will have
had a different experience going up or
down but it's still helpful to see and
leave those marks and so seek advice
seek Mentors
if there's one regret that I have it
wasn't good enough about seeking mentors
early on in my career because there's so
many mistakes that you can avoid by just
asking people for help along the way and
the other big piece and one thing I'm
more proud of as I've gotten to a
certain age is that you leave them for
the others as they come down pay it
forward know there was often there was
times where we ended up on a very
different path and with our we actually
had a GPS and navigation we managed to
get back onto the right place but we
said we went back and it took us about
an hour but to leave the Karan's for the
others coming behind behind us because
we recognized that it was going to be
really challenging if we didn't actually
we've some markers so you hiked up this
this that that face trail and the face
trail is essentially two miles straight
up it felt like 90 degrees I'm just
gonna say it was like this it certainly
felt like that for me I was bred I was
exhausted and you come around a bend and
you start to see this trail and
it looks here the trails out ahead of
you and I can see Table Rock on the
future and I am thinking as my daughter
likes to say easy-peasy like okay I've
got this the worst is behind me and now
I'm gonna be able to move forward and it
looks accessible it looks like something
I can almost touch it right that
perspective has changed but it's it's
close enough I can almost touch it this
is very true of professional careers I
don't know how many of you read Angela
Duckworth or grit and different the
first trajectories the of any kind of
learning a new scale getting into a
profession it's the steepest it's also
the most kind of thrilling because
you're just trying to you're just moving
forward you're putting it all out and
giving it all to just getting to that
next level of success and then you hit a
point where it often feels like a
plateau this well you think it's
actually the good part is actually one
of the most dangerous parts of any any
journey or any professional trajectory
and that's because you want things to be
easy
you think because you've gotten to a
certain point that you deserve it you
can see it it should happen and
oftentimes people don't actually push
themselves beyond it so you can see
there's like a little dark kind of blip
in that that has an arrow it was a my
about a mile of this that little blip in
the disk you couldn't actually see there
was no trail
it was completely just a rocks and every
single step was one where you could
sprain your ankle it wasn't as
treacherous as the climb it wasn't as
physically exhausting right but it was a
slog and you felt that that phase seemed
to take forever because you did not feel
like you were moving forward this is
something that happens pretty frequently
in life and it's really hard and
sometimes you just have to remember that
even though it feels like a slog and you
don't feel like you're making nearly as
much progress as you would you're
putting it all you're putting out there
but it's just one step in front of the
other
just remember forward momentum it's okay
and then the same way that you couldn't
see from that slide before it didn't
look like there was a challenge this is
often time what I see with a lot of the
companies that I'm involved in is they
go through the scaling thing they've
raised tons of
money they have great board of directors
they've got revenues and everyone from
the outside thinks this is easy-peasy
it's just gonna be a path and scaling
businesses hiring lots of employees the
problems become different the problems
become a different kind of complexity
and it's not as sexy it's not as fun and
it feels like a slog and it's hard
because from the outside everyone thinks
you should use racing up to the top of
the mountain but you've been slowed down
so when you hate one of those periods of
your life and you will you will get
through the rock field it is possible
but take time don't sprain an ankle then
there's other kinds of challenges so
getting up to that very very edge of the
table rock was essentially there was no
trail it was just free freeform climbing
straight up the hill and this sometimes
there the the rock field is possible
there's nothing now you know you can get
through it
it's just gonna be a grind at slog it's
not fun there are other phases where
you're not sure you're actually gonna be
able to make it it doesn't seem
physically possible doesn't seem
mentally possible it seems like
everything is stacked against you
you have companies that can't raise a
round of capital you have companies
where their largest customer suddenly
quits you have friends that get sick
that's something as you get older in
life you start to have different kind of
complexities different kind of of
challenges and one of the things I've
seen over and over is that you just have
to recognize that you gonna do the best
you can going up this and you're gonna
get hurt and bruised along the way I got
some pretty pretty nasty bruises I got a
really nice gash trying to make my way
up this and I had my brother who was an
amazing support person for me pulling me
and trying to get there and getting some
of the Rope set so it wouldn't be quite
as as challenging but some of those
times are gonna happen and you just have
to give it a whole you can to get
through it this is what it ends up when
you look like and I don't know how many
of you guys care about the mountains but
this was one of my the favorite things
I've seen it was just absolutely
gorgeous but you're also and this isn't
the purview you get up to this table
rock and you look around and you feel a
sense of accomplishment and I'm happy
and then I look around I recognize there
are all of these other peaks around me
they are all
I have just worked my ass off and
there's still a lot of other cooler
places to go that even have better views
and that is one of the hardest things
about going through these journeys is
once you actually get again that
perspective once you get to one point
you just get a different purview and you
start to even open up Rother and broader
possibilities of what's what's possible
I know a lot of really really successful
people I've got the privilege in the
last two decades to get to know many
people on different stages of their
journeys and one of the travesties is
knowing these extremely successful
people who end up being so deeply deeply
unhappy and one of the things you
constantly see that is there is that
they can't take the moment to both enjoy
their success and still be excited by
the challenges of climbing those other
peaks and knots and the duopoly that
you're gonna have to get comfortable
with as you think through this that you
want to actually you want to to
celebrate the hard work you want to
celebrate when you have these moments
and you get to those those peaks but you
also have to recognize there's gonna be
valleys and other peaks ahead of it and
that's okay too
don't get too daunted if it isn't you're
not ever gonna be on the highest peak in
the world you're not ever gonna be the
most successful person in the world and
stay there you can have those moments
and be happy but also recognize there's
other challenges ahead how many of you
guys are an Instagram I don't know is
that's still cool some not many one of
the things that I find really daunting
in this current environment is how much
we all got in and we get inundated
Instagram Facebook snapchat whatever the
current node is with the highlight reel
alright so this was the picture I took
this is what got posted on Instagram
right yay look at me I am so awesome I'm
at the top of this mountain there wasn't
a picture of me red-faced and panting
there wasn't a picture of my brother
just doing everything possible to try to
pull my fat butt up the side of the hill
none of those were make it to the glory
shots but this one does and so I think
it's really important as you guys think
about particulars you're inundated with
more and more of those highlight reels
more and more of those pictures of
people coming in is recognizing that for
every accomplishments for every one of
those moments that you want to
I am the peak there's an enormous amount
of other there's the behind-the-scenes
there were other challenges there were a
lot of ugly things that often had to
happen to make something look pretty
this is even no more true than it is and
I see this over business I mentioned
that I was on the board of of red fin
and in professional successes you tend
to see the person when they're on the
cover of the magazine or we celebrate
these moments right so this is one red
fin went public about two years ago and
everyone is smiling and beaming and it
looks like a ten year overnight success
right obvious great founder everyone's
high-fiving each other also everyone
wants to be in this picture those
moments of success that's where your
everybody comes out of the woodwork and
wants to be right by your side with a
big smile I invested in the company in
2007 2008 we had the financial crisis
the real estate market completely tanked
no one who wanted to buy home could get
a loan and those people that didn't want
to sell a home on our platform the
prices were 30 to 40 percent lower we
had to have had a board meeting about a
year into the investor and half into the
investment where I sat with the friendly
smiley guy Glenn Kalman in the middle
who was shaking and trying to hold back
tears because we had to layoff 20% of
the company it was critical to be able
to get the company through this phase we
knew the revenues we're gonna slow we
knew that we needed to make the money
last a little bit longer but he had
hired those people he had told those
individuals that he was gonna do
everything possible to ensure the
success of his company and he felt
deeply conflicted and like a failure
that he hadn't been able to live up to
that promise that's not a moment where
you whip out your camera and say hey
cheese I want to take this and remember
this in the dark times right those
moments aren't captured and oftentimes
those moments aren't even told but for
any of those glory moments that you see
you have multiple stories like that in
the background and what you need to do
is recognize that sometimes those people
that surround you you want to celebrate
the glory moment and it's okay to have
those people come but make sure that the
people who are with you when the times
are really really tough are also there
because those are the true people that
you really need by your side those are
the ones that know
it took for you to get there and I can
understand who you are and who you had
to become in order to have that kind of
success so I get up there and you think
yeah I'm done and I'm not it's actually
a shorter hike up than it is to go down
and that was a really so really was just
starting I wasn't even halfway done with
the day and that is one of the really
important things to recognize is that
you start these things and you're just
beginning anytime you think you have a
moment of success or you think you've
rich reached something there's always
another place to go I call this the if
only phenomenon and I really my husband
and I ended up going through a phase
where we started to ban if only if only
I get into Stanford everything will be
okay if only I could get a job at this
firm then things will be better if only
I could make this amount of money then
life would totally change and what we've
realized is we had our if only if only
and as soon as you go past him you
realize there was a whole new set of if
onlys and there was never that moment
where you felt fully relieved now
obviously when you have you don't have
to worry about making rent those are
free there are some decent things that
make life easier I don't want to take
away from that but these if only is that
thinking that there's a magical place or
a magical accomplishment will somehow
transform everything it just doesn't
exist the other thing that's really
interesting is that going down was a
very different physical phenomenon you
think it's really challenging to go up
and it is it's it's an exertion you are
going everything you can to try to climb
that hell and then you get there and you
start heading down and you no longer
fighting gravity right gravity is now
your friend but that weight had a whole
new set of problems
right that hurt your knees and my hips
and it was really treacherous because if
you fall on the way down you don't just
kind of fall for it and catch yourself
you go rolling right and I sometimes
feel like success is this for people
it's gravity so it's a little bit you
should think it should make it easier
right like you've actually gotten there
you have gravity on your side but it can
also be a real burden and
trained and sometimes the implications
of that become even bigger when you get
to a point you think gravity you think I
can just fly down and that never really
works you still have to be methodical in
some ways you almost have to slow down
and be even more careful and make sure
you even have better trail companions to
hold your hand so you don't stumble and
fall because that fall is the one that
could really do you n when I see
different people in different
trajectories of success one of the most
important things is keeping that
feedback loop making sure there are
people that keep them honest there's
actually been a study that was done the
Atlantic wrote a great article about it
that basically showed that people with
power can sometimes experience something
that's relative to mental illness where
power actually has the thing to
physically change your mind and I was
telling us to a friend and she said yeah
well of course like the only people who
throw tantrums are three-year-olds and
billionaires three-year-olds because
they're pushing the limits to see and
get told no and billionaires because no
one ever tells them no anymore so they
lose that no idea of how to actually
control themselves and so when you think
about that weight you get two different
phases of your life sometimes it's
equally important to make sure that you
have those people who say no because as
you're going down if you're like I could
run down the hill like I'm this great
person because I say yeah sure you get a
lot of yes people you gotta get a lot of
sycophants who want to tell you what you
think you want to hear and it's really
really critical in those moments make
sure that you have the right people by
you who are keeping you honest who tell
you when to slow down so you don't
actually take that deep fumble or duper
stumble down the hill so this is the the
same kind of thing we keep talking about
is that it's the it's the peaks and
valleys and that's it
you always have to dig down deep and
start to think about where you want to
go next
recognize that it life it's it's it's
long but it's also short and so you
really want to think about how you can
enjoy you know the different stages of
it we went through this this this hike
and as I came down I was struck at how
that last portion of the hike had some
of the most beautiful parts of it
because I actually took some time to
look and I could
on the way up I took no photos other
than that that that trail sign and on
the way down I took multiple photos and
I will spare you of those but there was
a momma moose and a baby moose there was
baby bears climbing up there was you
know these amazing mountain ridges and
you can't even capture the glory of the
of these wildflowers that were just
there just fields and fields of
wildflowers and it was the same like
this was the same area but I actually
took the time to step back and enjoy
some of it and start to think about
where I would go next so here's some of
the kind of takeaways if you will use
the trail as your guide it's a guide but
it's not guardrails again every like the
trail changes daily based off of the
conditions every single one of you will
have your own journey you'll have your
own challenges your own opportunities
but take the time to kind of see how
others have gone before you learn from
their lessons listen to some of that
perspective because it could help make
your journey a little bit better choose
your trail companions wisely the obvious
thing is everyone says like who you
choose as your life partner it's more
than true I can honestly say I would not
be here without you know my husband but
also a couple of really really important
and key friends and those are the people
that are the behind the scenes but but
don't worry about the highlight reel and
they're not the ones who are liking me
on Instagram or retweeting when I have a
good moment but the people that I can
have real conversations with who spend
the real time with me we're really
really bad at visualizing the future and
just the same way I had no idea what I
was going as I saw you know that that
that little lump out in the distance you
don't know you can set aspirations but
you don't know what your future holds I
was talking with a good friend who was
had dinner with a well-known and of
rights to this story so I will the
billionaire a female you all know and
she was talking to how very early on in
her career she went to a successful
person's home and sat on the patio to
talk about a business deal and she
looked out in his backyard
and there were eight trees and she sat
there and thought wow
one day I hope I'm rich enough
that I can have a house with a big
backyard and get eight trees fast
forward many decades later many homes
later she was at her ranch in Southern
California looking out at her backyard
on multiple acres and thought I have a
lot of trees I wonder how many trees I
actually had so she wouldn't hired
someone to go and count the trees and it
was seventy-five thousand trees that
were on this property I talk about is
like it's not those bold aspirations
severan saying what can other people you
know what does the other success look
like those are good there again those
are interesting trails and you can learn
from that but you have no idea what
you're really capable of you don't know
what your future can actually hold and
keep that in mind because it's not fixed
it's not gonna happen on a certain
timeline and you could all find your own
forests in your own way and this like
this thing of don't let if I could have
one thing I really really want everyone
to take away because I struggled with
this for a long time early on is don't
let anyone else define what you're
capable of or tell you what success
should look like a good friend of mine
always says you can't be what you can't
see and that's been a big movement for
us a lot of the the female women and the
female partners in venture capital are
trying to be more prominent because we
realize for us to be able to recruit
more women into venture they need to see
that you can be successful as a woman in
the industry
and that's all well and good and that's
true you want to have more prominent
people but I also hope we get to the
point where you don't need to see it to
believe it
you don't need to see someone else who
looks like you or has the same
background as you or follow that to
believe that you're capable of it don't
let any sign or any definition of
another person's what it takes to be
successful to hold you back so the last
little pit set your sight I get started
never give up but the trail and the
desperation destination will surprise
you